tell us what would you do how would your
response be we
we've seen something in the media uh you
know you're coming out of a
mosque or a masjid or an event and you
know a a
family gathering and then outside of the
mosque
you had someone holding a sign
saying go back home
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're patriotic americans and we love
our constitution and we're going to stay
that way
get out of here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
how would you respond to this uh if i go
back home i go to houston because
houston is my home
i was born here in texas so if i go back
home that's where i go back home yeah
and submission to god is a universal
message so wherever
a person lives or a creature lives
that's their home
yeah and in other words submission to
god is something that should be done
regardless of where a person is
how's your relationship with jesus now
as opposed to then uh
if you read the new testament and you
simply don't know what's going on
you find a character who you believe
intended good
but is very mixed up and that would be
the view
of jesus now now with islam
you can then understand what jesus was
about which was
essentially uh he believed that it was
his role from god
to show israel how to be the example for
the world to follow and submission to
god and take care of
care of their fellow creature and um
eventually uh when he felt that he was
rejected by israel
uh if you check say for instance matthew
21 43
he told the leaders of
you know jewish community that the
kingdom of god would be taken from them
and given to
another nation or
[Music]
our community that would in fact do what
they were told to do
and then for instance if you check john
you'll see that there was
to come a comforter who would
be a perfect guide a lot of christians
for instance
might say that this refers to god the
holy spirit but then again if you take
the same source you see that
this comforter had to be told what to do
in other words he didn't speak of
himself he spoke of what someone else
told him
in other words he could hardly be a god
who doesn't know what to say or has to
have someone tell them what to
say you've written a book called the
last christian yes
what's this book primarily focus on okay
uh
it uh it isn't the theme that it is
involved in is trying to differentiate
the jesus of history the person who
actually walked the earth and the jesus
of faith
uh the first half the book is largely
concerned we're trying to uh
explore how the jesus of uh faith came
to be
the second half is trying to put
together the jesus of history
the book is called the last christian
because
jesus the historical character you know
is not the same as the jesus of faith
so in that sense he's asked christian
also problem you have in trying to
reconstruct the historical jesus
is you can find indications or you can
find things that indicate what the
historical character was but very often
you can say well i know i got something
here but it's hard for me to say how
firm it is so it'd be much like a
building a structure or a house where
say well i know i got a piece of straw
here this piece would i even think i
have a board here
and that's in that sense jesus last
christian because you can't completely
reconstruct the historical
jesus now what you do find is that all
the indications of the historical jesus
do not conform with the jesus of faith
you know
amazing we're gonna we're gonna take a
break and then we're gonna take some
questions from our live audience when we
come back
okay we'll be right back here with more
here on the dean show
and with good deeds uh we'll find that
good breeds
good clear out
your mind and your heart of hatred
and preconceived notions racism
and nationalism because you cannot have
anything inside of you that's like that
against
people and still be successful
[Music]
welcome back to the dean show and we're
here with the author of the last
christian david
mr david thank you again for being with
us we're gonna go ahead
we're here in texas y'all and we're
going to go ahead and
get some questions from the live studio
audience
here on the dean show follow me all
right it's not the oprah
show this is the gene show and we have
our brother mujahid
please step up here got a question for
david
uh yes david
within the 50 years as a as i hear you
have
uh extensive history in regards to
speaking to people
about god and the message of god
how did that differ whenever you
embraced islam
um it's very rare that we actually see
muslims going to places and
you know knocking on people's doors or
kind of doing the sort of
kind of evangelical work let's say uh do
you find that
it's a bit different now to talk about
god or the format
and not necessarily going to the people
maybe like you had in the past how how
did that change how do you deal with
that now
a big difference if you're going to be
like a
christian missionary or a preacher and
that's
that sort of thing when you talk about
god you're primarily
talking to people because you want to
get them into heaven because you want
them to believe
in the divine sacrifice of god's divine
son when you're talking to people in
islam
you're trying to tell them the message
of all the prophets which is also the
message of
jesus that they should make god central
to their life and they should
show or prove it by taking care of their
fellow human being and you would then
when you talk about islam you would
simply tell them that essentially what
you have in islam
is you have a tried and proven living
community that has done just that that
has a record of how to do that and
that is what you speak about when you
speak about islam thank you
we're going to move on to the next
question
young young brother please come up step
up here and go ahead and ask your
question
to uh david go ahead all right islam
welcome
um i heard there is an old testament uh
recording that says to tell to be able
to distinguish a true
prophet and a false prophet and uh that
a false prophet
or will be the one who tells false
prophecies they prophesize about some of
it doesn't come true
now um so we have this issue or this
conflict of the teachings of paul
and jesus christ peace be upon him
what are some of the prophecies of paul
and did they come true
okay essentially uh
at some time during jesus's time on
earth his ministry he came to the
conclusion
that israel was not going to accept him
as their messiah
and he then said according to say
matthew 21 43 that
god's kingdom would be taken from
israel and would be given to another
nation or another community
that in fact would do what they're told
to do now
paul who uh would either was either who
was a jewish scholar
or partisan or a zealot this didn't go
down very well with them
according to the record as one finds it
in the new testament he first was a
persecutor people who followed jesus
then
he had a nervous breakdown and after his
nervous breakdown he said that jesus
came to him
in a series of visions and dreams and he
told them
you know his message and you find that
in this message
you have a different jesus from all the
indications of the jesus
who actually walked the earth now
paul the thing remember about paul is
that paul said everything he taught or
preached or believed or said or did
came from jesus now in two occasions
for example uh book of first corinthians
chapter seven
paul tells the people that jesus's time
and he's going to be coming back is so
short it doesn't matter that if they
rejoice don't rejoice marry marry or
don't marry uh
buy or or don't buy doesn't matter now
this is 1900 years ago this didn't
happen
you find in the fourth chapter of first
thessalonians that he was telling his
audience the people from desolate
that before everybody there was dead
jesus was coming back this didn't happen
now remember he said that jesus told him
everything that would happen in the
future
and paul certainly at some time during
his lifetime believe that jesus was god
so paul was saying that god told him
this and that it didn't happen so either
you should believe
god told him this or that is paul making
a mistake and
where this is a test of a prophet is
you'll find
in deuteronomy chapter 18
it says that a prophet if he speaks in
the name of god
and he tells you something's going to
happen it doesn't happen it's a false
prophet
giving a false prophecy and don't listen
to him here in texas thank you very much
and we're going to go to the next we
have
time for one more question young man
young man please come up and ask your
question
wait hold on before you start see we're
in texas i haven't heard nobody say
y'all
no go ahead how are you doing no
yes um you mentioned earlier that some
people may see
throughout your your time as a muslim
that people have seen islam to be
foreign
what are some things that you think that
practices that muslims muslims can
undergo in order to
eliminate that or what have you seen
through your lifestyle that
muslims have practiced or that the
perception have been from non-muslims
concerning this
okay uh the question of perception is
you
uh you have a community that is
distinct or different and
muslims should just simply concentrate
on being
if they're distinct or different and
being distinct or different in a good
way which is what muslims are supposed
to do
supposed to make god central to life and
take care of their fellow human being
and as long as they practice that
they're fine thank you very much and
that is it for now we're going to take a
break
and we're going to be back with more
here
live the dean show in texas y'all
sit tight i am not afraid
i am not afraid to stand alone if allah
[Music]
is
and if we're going to worship something
i figured i might as well worship the
creator
instead of any of the creations now
upon investigating all the religions i
remember finding out the meaning of what
islam is what a muslim is
those who surrender their self to god is
a muslim
those who surrender submit to god god's
will
that is it islam was pure it was just
you just pray to god your creator
back here on the dean's show live in
texas and we're here with david the
author of the last christian
we have a few more minutes okay before
the show comes to a
end and i have just a few more points i
want to cover did you get a chance to
watch
these senate hearings with the pepe king
peter king
only for a few minutes yeah i really
didn't get to watch that much of it
they were coming together
discussing the radicalization of youth
so basically when you see
some of the politicians who are really
supposed to be working to create
understanding
you know between the people bringing
people together but we really want
the politicians and people out there to
understand us better because maybe they
have good intentions but
they they're misunderstanding us okay so
here's here's what i or what i would say
yeah uh
the question is about whether muslims
are or not good citizens
the constitution defines what a good
citizen is and the preamble says
we the people of the united states in
order to form a more perfect union
to establish justice ensure domestic
tranquility
to provide for the common defense to
promote the general welfare
to uh secure for ourself from posterity
the blessings of liberties do establish
and ordain this constitution
united states any emotion that can say
that is a good muslim
and most muslims can say that most
muslims will embrace that most
muslims are good americans that's right
i like that masha allah so before we
come to an end tell us now where can
people if they want to read your book
the last christian
where can i get this okay
simply remember the title last question
go online
you can go to either amazon.com or
barnes and noble the people who actually
publish this book are author house like
i'm the author and i live in a house
author house
go online they sell the book as well
they also sell it as an e-book
hopefully a texas company texas global
traders will also soon be selling the
book
uh but uh remember my name david gullion
and the title last christian
and you can simply buy it online it'd be
the quickest easiest way to do it
i'd like to thank you and any closing
comments for those who are out there
and the way of life that they're living
they're not happy with it it's confusing
and and they want to step out of the
confusion and they're just a little bit
timid you know
culture class sometimes they see muslims
as people who
they just can't identify with but they
can identify with islam
what advice do you have for them
islam if it's practiced the way it's
supposed to be
means peace it also means the best form
of life
in others if a person makes god the
center of their life
and by doing so they take care of their
fellow human being they make the world a
better place
and that is what islam is all about
thank you very much thank you very much
may god almighty the creator
reward you for being with us thank you
so much and thank you again for tuning
in to another episode of the dean show
you might not like spicy food neither do
i you might not like dress in a certain
way you like dressing your way
as long as this is a modest way don't
worry about it you can do it
in islam it's all good as long as it's
pleasing to the creator of the heavens
and the earth and as
you heard our guests say making god the
central point in your life
just worshiping god not worshiping jesus
not worshiping
statues icons idols monkeys elephants
none of these things
only worshiping the creator and doing
good doing good to your neighbor doing
good to your parents
doing good to your fellow brothers and
sisters in humanity
this is what islam is about and you met
an american
you met an american we've interviewed
romanians hispanics
islam is the fastest growing way of life
in the world and thank you for coming
to the source to learn about the most
misunderstood yet fastest growing way of
life in the world islam
practiced by over 1.5 billion and you
could be a muslim too
you can be a muslim too because a muslim
is simply one who takes that free choice
that they have
of either submitting to the creation of
god or submitting to god and
you know what the right thing to do is
submit to the one jesus submitted to
that's the one god the one creator and
do good deeds do righteousness
and this is what islam is calling you to
get a free copy of the quran call the
number on the screen 1-800-662-islam
read the verbatim word of god and
continue to come back here to the d-show
until next time we started with people
we end with peace peace be unto you
come and see what everyone's talking
about if you find one contradiction it
can't be from god
but the rational idea the rational
explanation is you do your best give up
worshipping god is one i will never give
up spending this message
i hope that you take that necessary step
you don't know if you're gonna live
until tomorrow
so you gotta find that urgency to do the
right thing right now
if you say that you do not believe in
jesus you have stepped outside of islam
you cannot be a muslim and attended our
faith too
[Music]
bismillah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
m
[Music]
m
[Music]
moon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
yes
you